翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Koji Nagai
遡りますこと 1950年
宮崎県の幸島という小さな島に
お猿さんが住んでいます
ニホンザルのメスの仔ザルで
当時 1.5歳の
のちに「イモちゃん」と名付けられた
サルなんですが
その子が大発明をします
その発明とは
ヒトから与えられたサツマイモを
まずは淡水に漬けて 砂を落として
さらには海水に漬けて 塩味までつけて
食べるという発明でした
この行動はその後 彼女の遊び仲間
さらにはそれぞれのお母さん達に伝わり
4、5年経つと 群れの過半数の個体に
伝わるということが起きた訳ですね
これが有名な
「幸島のニホンザルの芋洗い」
という「文化」なんです
なぜ 本能ではなくて
「文化」なのかといいますと
まず行動を新しく開発した
獲得したということですね
さらにはそれが 個体の学習 —
試行錯誤による学習
という側面もありますけど
親しい者同士を通じて
伝わっていった ということから
「社会的に学習された行動である」
と考えられたからです
これが 人以外の動物で
初めて見つかった「文化」として
その当時 注目を浴びた訳です
当時 日本のサル学の
初期にあたる訳ですが
日本のサル学の初期においては
こういう形で
ヒトでしか見られていない行動が
ヒト以外の動物でも
見られたということで
ヒトの ある系譜をたどる
という研究において
ニホンザルが重要な役割を
演じることになった訳です
ただ その後 ヒトの行動の
系譜をたどる研究において
ヒトに近い チンパンジーや
ゴリラなどの類人猿 —
英語では「Ape」と言いますが
そういった霊長類に ある種
主役の座を奪われる形になります
その後も もちろん ニホンザルのような
「モンキー」の研究も進んでいく訳ですが
ニホンザルの研究はむしろ
人類学的な研究というよりも
動物学的な研究として
進んでいくことになります
さて本日は 文化と 文化の系譜を
たどることにフォーカスを当てて
その発見に導くような「発想力」の話を
今日はしたいと思います
また遡りますこと 1984年
この年に私は京都大学の
霊長類研究所というところの
大学院の修士課程に入学しました
研究者の卵になる訳ですから
研究テーマを考えないといけない
さらにそれに沿った仮説を考えなくては
いけないということ
そこで研究室において
つまり机上でですね
いろいろ先行研究 —
これまでどういう研究があるのか
ということを調べたり
さらには 先生たち先輩たちの
話を聞いたりして
なんとかある仮説を打ち立てて
それを携えて宮城県の
金華山島という所に行きました
そこで こういう形で ニホンザルという
「モンキー」を観察しながら
自分自身が立てた
仮説に合うようなデータ
サポートするようなデータを
集めようとした訳です
ところがしばらくして
このように観察していても
どうも私が机上で考えた仮説が
当てはまらないような気がして
ならなくなった訳ですね
で これは「困った」と
「どないしょうか？」と
困り果てた訳ですが
結果的には
現場で考えた発想によって
なんとか研究ができた訳です
今日は そのうちの
現場で考えた発想の
一つを紹介します
それが金華山のニホンザルで見られた
「ハグ」
抱擁という行動です
「百聞は一見にしかず」
ということで まず
動画で見ていただきますが
右のニホンザルが 左のニホンザルに
毛づくろいをしています
左の個体が起き上がって —
普通ならお返しの毛づくろいを
するはずなんですが
しません
で 右の個体はちょっと苛立っています
「もうあんたの番やのに
なんでせえへんねん？」
みたいな感じで ちょっと苛立って
自分の体をかきむしっている訳ですが
「まだせえへんで こいつ！」
みたいな感じで 今度は
お尻までかきむしってですね
「でもうしゃあないから 自分でしよかー」
みたいな感じで毛づくろいをしたら
おもむろに ハグが起きる訳です
で 大きく腕を相手に回して
前後に体を大きく揺するというハグですね
ハグが起きる場面は他にもあります
ケンカです
口を尖んがらせて
相手を威嚇しているんですが
彼女たちの視線の先には
このメスがいます
悲鳴をあげています
ぎゃあぎゃあ言うてます
で このケンカを売る方と買う方がいて
それがお互いに近づき合って
ハグが起きるということがあります
そしてその後はスムーズにこうやって
毛づくろいに移行するという訳ですね
このようにハグの直前に
毛づくろいの中断も起こらなければ
或いは ケンカも起きないという場合に
ハグが起きるという場合があるんですが
それは お互いに
あんまり仲が良くない者同士 —
正確に言えば
あんまり普段毛づくろいをしない者同士が
その後毛づくろいをするにあたって
その直前にハグをするというパターンです
という風なことを考えてみますと
どうもこの「ハグ」というのは
ちょっと緊張した場面で起きている
ということがわかります
つまり「ハグ」というのは
その緊張をある種 緩和する —
軽減する —
そういう機能があるんだ
ということがわかりました
私は別に「ハグ」の研究をしようと思って
この島にやって来た訳じゃないんですけど
偶然 この行動を発見して
しかもこの行動は
ヒトでもするような行動ですよね？
ある種ありふれた 普通の行動から
発見をするということになった訳です
このように 偶然
普通のありふれた出来事から
発見をするという能力のことを
英語でこういう言葉があるそうです
「セレンディピティ」
という言葉なんですが
ご存知でしょうか？
この語の由来はですね
「セレンディップ」という国 —
現在のスリランカにあたるようですが
その国に伝わる寓話から来ています
その国の王さんが
若い王子たち３人に
「お前ら ちょっと旅に行ってこい」と
王子たちは それで それに従って
旅に行く訳ですが
旅に出た先で いろんな発見をしてくる
という物語です
その１つを紹介しますと
自分たちの目の前を
ラクダが歩いています
ラクダが草を食んでいる訳ですが
左っ側の草ばっかりなくなって
右っ側が残っている ということから
王子たちは
「きっとラクダは左目は見えるんだけど
右目があまりよく見えないんじゃないか？」
ということに気づいた訳です
さて この「セレンディピティ」
というのに匹敵するような —
相当するような言葉を
ニホンザルの 先ほどの
芋洗いの発見に導いた
伊谷純一郎先生が
このような言葉を残されています
「自然が微笑む時を 見逃さない力」
素晴らしい言葉だと思われませんか？
私はですね この
「自然が微笑む時を 見逃さない力」にせよ
「セレンディピティ」にせよ
その時の感性が高まっている
という状態が重要だと思っています
その感性が —
その感性を高まらせる環境は
私にとってはフィールドだ
という実感を持っています
と言いますのも
フィールドに出ると我々は
まずサルを探すところから始まります
双眼鏡を手にして
「サル おらんかー？」という形で
視覚的にサルを探す
更には サルの声を聞きながら
つまり 聴覚を利用して探す
で 時には嗅覚
サルの臭いを頼りにしてサルを探す
見つけた後も サルの行動の
一挙手一投足を見逃すまいとして
感覚神経を総動員して
サルの行動を観察している訳です
だからそういう
感性が高まっている —
そういう状況においてこそ
新しい発想 あるいは思考に磨きがかかると
体験的にそう思っている訳ですね
この写真も
なんか しかめっ面をしていますが
これはヤラセじゃないんです
偶然 後輩が撮ってくれた写真で
「え？俺 こんな顔をしてサルを見てんねんや」
と思ってちょっと驚いたぐらいなんですが
多分 なんかその時
考えてたんでしょうね
だと 思います
最近 私は京大で
教員をしているんですが
最近の京大生はですね
割と やっぱり 頭でっかちで
なかなか
フィールドに行ってくれないんですね
だから 私は彼らに
「まず現場に行きなさいよ」と
「現場に行って その対象物 —
サルですね — サルを見て来なさい
そうすると サルがテーマを
与えてくれるから」
「ま 行っておいで」
みたいな話をする訳ですね
実際に私がそうだったから
そう言っているんですが
私がこれまでいくつかの発見をしたうち
過半数は そういう現場で得た発想を
元にした発見だった訳です
今日お集まりのみなさんも
クリエイティブな仕事を
されている方も多いでしょうし
スピーカーの方も
今日もいろんな発想の話を
新しい発想の話をしてくださいましたが
それぞれみなさんが新しい発想を
得た時を思い出していただければ
今の私の話も共感して
もらえるんじゃないかと思っています
さて また少し遡ります
10年くらいです
2006年ですかね？
それまでの間
私はちょっとアフリカに行って
別のアフリカのモンキーの研究を
していたんですが
久々に 今度は「屋久島」という
ニホンザルの分布の
南限にあたるところのサルの
交尾行動の研究調査に行きました
ところが 見ていると
屋久島のサルがハグをしているんですね
「ない」と言われていたんです
「ハグはしないよ」
と言われてたんですが
「してるやん？」
ただ 「ちょっと違うなあ」と —
「金華山で私が見たパターンと
ちょっと違うなあ」
ということに また気づく訳です
じゃあ 屋久島のパターンを
見ていただきますから
どこが同じか どこが違うのか
見てください
やはり 相手に腕を回していますから
これは「ハグ」です
口をちょっととんがらせて
もぐもぐしています —
「リップスマッキング」
という表情が見て取れます
だいたいこれで お気づきだと思いますが
一応念のために比べてみます
左っ側が金華山で
右側が屋久島です
右はスローになっていますけれども
まずお気づきなのは
金華山の方は対面で抱き合っています
それに対して 屋久島 —
右っ側の方は 横から抱きついていますよね
もちろん 正面 —
対面も屋久島ではあるんですけれども
こういう側面のパターンが
屋久島にはあるということ
もう一つ どうでしょう？
屋久島はですね 相手をつかんだ手のひらを
微妙に動かしていますよね
手のひらを開いたり閉じたり
開いたり閉じたりというような動作をします
それに対して 左っ側の金華山は
それはなくて
その代わりと言っちゃなんですが 体をこうして
大きく前後に揺するというパターンです
このように
地域によって ハグの —
抱擁のパターンが違うと
これはきっと文化的な違いじゃないかと
いう風に私は思っている訳です
色々その金華山 屋久島で
ハグをする抱擁行動がある場所と
実はない場所もたくさんあります
幸島という芋洗で有名なところは
しません
こういう風にあるなしというのも
やはり文化的な違いなんだろうと
私は思っています
冒頭でお話しした 幸島の芋洗ですね
これはいわば「食文化」でした
「食」ですから 生き死に
生死というのに
深く関連した文化になります
ところがこちらの抱擁行動の方は
ちょっと生死というのとは
生き死にとは 遠い話ですね
その代わり 相手がいる行動です
いわば社会行動の文化
ということができるでしょう
社会行動の文化というと ヒトの場合
どういうものが当てはまるかというと
これですね
挨拶ですね
挨拶が国によって 民族によって
地域によって違い
それが文化だということは
みなさんよくご存知のことだと思います
社会行動の文化の系譜をたどるという時に
ヒトだけ見ていてもダメだ
ということは自明ですね
じゃあ ヒトに近い
チンパンジーだとかゴリラなどの
類人猿を見ればいいのか？
確かにチンパンジーは
ここにあります通り
ある毛づくろいの仕方が
地域によって違う
そしてそれは文化である
ということがわかっています
ただ ここまでの話で
お分りの通りですね
類人猿よりさらにヒトから遠い
旧世界ザルに分類されるニホンザルにも
こういう抱擁行動という
社会行動の文化が見つかった訳です
じゃあ ここまでで良いか？
というと
実はそうではなくて
さらに遠い
中南米に棲んでいる新世界ザルの仲間の
オマキザルにも一風変わった社会行動が
ある地域とない地域がある
ということも知られています
地域によってパターンが違う
というのは知られていないんですが
ある地域とない地域
というのが知られています
こう考えますと
もっと原始的な霊長類 —
さらに言えば 霊長類以外の哺乳類にも
ひょっとするとこの先
社会行動の文化が見られるかもしれません
こういう風にヒトの行動の
系譜をたどる研究において
類人猿に主役の座が
奪われた形になっていたニホンザルですが
それから30年あまり経ってですね
もう一度ニホンザルから
その関連の発見をすることができました
そこで重要な位置を占めたのが
「セレンディピティ」という
ある種の発想の力です
今後ひょっとすると
より原始的な霊長類や
他の哺乳類にも
社会行動の文化が
見られるかもしれません
もし見つかるとすると
やはりそこでも
セレンディピティという発想力が
有効な力を発揮してくれるのでは
ないかという風に思っています
以上です
ご静聴ありがとうございました
(拍手）